y la crítica situación que se está
viviendo en colombia está ocupando
titulares en la prensa internacional el
miércoles coincidiendo con la segunda
convocatoria de paro nacional el diario
británico the gardian abrió una línea de
whatsapp para que los colombianos
reporten los casos de violencia policial
la grave situación durante las protestas
fue también portada del medio
estadounidense the new york times las
condenas internacionales se extienden a
medida que salen a la luz más casos de
violaciones de derechos humanos por
parte de la fuerza pública desde
organizaciones de derechos como human
rigth watch amnistía internacional hasta
la unión europea y naciones unidas para
actuar we can say clearly sandwich
lo que podemos decir claramente es que
hemos recibido informes y tenemos que
stieg así es el uso excesivo de la
fuerza por parte de los agentes de
seguridad suris pares munición real que
se utiliza golpes a los manifestantes y
también detenciones
es igual a de teis jones un grupo de
parlamentarios alemanes se envió una
carta al presidente colombiano iván
duque clamando por la aplicación de las
normas internacionales para la
intervención policial
un llamado al cese de la represión que
resuena también en bruselas donde
cientos de colombianas en el exilio se
congregaron frente al parlamento europeo
que nos tienen que acompañar en nuestro
dolor y no permitir que el gobierno de
iván duque siga asesinando a los
colombianos solamente porque protestamos
por sus políticas nefastas desde chile a
panamá en américa latina' también clama
por justicia al grito de ese oeste
colombia para en esta masacre en
colombia frente al silencio
institucional son los organismos y
políticos en la oposición quienes exigen
al gobierno responsabilidades los
rectores de las universidades nacionales
enviaron una misiva a duke para promover
el diálogo buscar soluciones para la
crisis que vive el país desde el pasado
del futuro